just to say it is lovely to be back in
person and I find it wonderful that
Ukraine may be going up in Flames
women's rights in the US are in
Desperate Peril uh trans rights are
across the world seem to be in Desperate
Peril again still
um but at least we've solved diversity
in Tech I'm no longer presenting to a
room of 90 white men
oh wait
um yeah it's my perennial whinge
um we still need to do better uh take
this as a reminder that we still need to
do better
um and this is my other perennial
reminder I started doing slides like
this at the start and end of Dex uh back
in uh Caribbean Dev comp uh which was
obviously in the Caribbean and lovely I
was giving a talk on uh it wasn't on
kindness
um but it was
related to kindness and the organizer
said oh uh have you got slides and I
said no I haven't that's okay we'll
we'll put up a giant picture of you
behind and say no that would be a
terrible terrible thing just put
something up that says be kind
um and I've thought since then if I can
encourage people to show a tiny bit more
kindness and move the needle very
slightly there I would rather do that
than teach you about versioning and
dates and times and stuff and I'm sure
you're all very kind people anyway but I
tend to think that if I nudge a little
bit then aside from anything else I've
reminded myself that I need to be kind
so if the person on the tube just you
know barges me out the way just
take a take a moment be kind
boom today
um
this is extremely uh self
not self-deprecating there's a word it's
self-indulgent that's it
um because I'm basically talking about
what I've been doing for the last couple
of years
um and it's been a lot of fun doing the
coding and I've given this talk a few
times uh it has it evolved as the code
has been evolving
um but where out of Interest how many of
you are in down North talk in this room
in the last hour okay good because we're
going to evaluate some of this against
Dan's cupid is it does it count as a
framework down I don't know against the
cupid properties
um but where Dan's talk was very much
sort of
uh thought provoking and encouraging you
to think deeply I'm encouraging you to
feel passionately uh so you don't really
need to care about anything
that I've done what I want you to get is
the sense of how much I care about it
and how that has hopefully manifested in
the software and then in real world
usage and then you can think oh what
could I do that would be equally fun and
meaningful
so this last encourage you to go build
stuff is the real thing there are some
interesting Tech bits as well but
basically if right now you've thought oh
I know exactly what I will go out from
John's talk and build then go and start
building it now with a coffee that's
fine you've taken all the main messages
of the talk
so uh
one of the nice things about giving this
talk is I get to say I am a committed
Christian
um and I'm a Methodist local preacher
and I worship at tilehurst Methodist
Church
uh tilehurst small townish just to the
west of reading
um and I've been involved in the AV the
audio visual side of things for tahurst
Methodist Church for almost as long as
I've been there because as Dan said it's
it's the kind of thing you get uh roped
into
before the pandemic hit we had a
computer
a projector and a mixing desk
this was the mixing desk
perfectly good mixing desk so let's say
Mackie cfx12
it has
a sort of 12 input channels or 10
depending on how you count a couple that
are stereo
and down here these are called faders I
now know wouldn't have been able to tell
you that two two years ago
these are the important bits that
control the volumes
and these are the other important bits
that are mute buttons
nothing else was oh this is the master
the main volume controller that's
important nothing else is important
unless it's wrong
um all of these knobs and buttons are at
very specific places and if anyone moved
them it would be wrong and we wouldn't
know where
this was a call a source of considerable
scariness for me and other people in the
tech team and in particular the stewards
within the church who are sort of
responsible for making sure that worship
happens on a Sunday morning
also for a long time were responsible
for doing the AV so you would welcome
the the preacher or Minister
um give the notices then come and sit
down at the AV desk and be projecting
hymn words and muting and unmuting
microphones and a lot of people wanted
to be stewards they really really didn't
want to touch this
so that was the before times
next is church in lockdown because I'm
going to talk about two apps that I
built
um and while Dan mentioned that that
naming should be you know meaningful I
have meaningful but still Whimsical
names
um I had zoom and enhance
we did if you've seen all the uh NSI or
whatever it's called NCI um things where
they say okay well the reflection in
that person's sunglasses on the CCTV
camera uh clearly shows that the person
was wearing a Rolex watch because we'll
zoom and enhance and and see everything
um
the background is for a few weeks at the
start of the pandemic
TMC Tyler's Methodist Church
um did nothing
in fact a lot of stuff was happening in
the background a lot of pastoral work
checking that people were okay were able
to get shopping
Etc
then on Easter Day 2020 we had our our
first Zoom service and our minister at
the time Andy did everything he was very
very Hands-On so he would
um read a prayer or pray extemporary
probably
um and then start a screen share click
to play a video Etc we would all watch
the video then he would come back and
someone else might be doing a reading so
he would stop the screen share make sure
everyone was muted Spotlight the person
doing the reading unmute them
lots and lots of clicks
and at the same time he's meant to be
leading worship which you know I know
from experience is an energy consuming
and exhausting thing to do and wonderful
as well
it's all difficult so he was doing two
difficult jobs at the same time
and the next week I said why don't you
focus on the leading worship I will take
the zoom bit you know tell me what
videos you want to show uh what bits of
text or whatever and who we want to
Spotlight doing readings and I will do I
will do all the Frantic clicking
so I did
and it worked better and I thought
there's a lot of clicking I'd use zoom a
little bit before the pandemic a lot of
people had never heard of it before but
when you do screen sharing you do start
screen share then decide which screen
you want to share then if you've got a
video or whatever you then start the
video and sort of reverse it all for
spotlighting and things
and it seemed a lot of work but
fortunately I found that Zoom had a
c-sharp SDK
and I thought I wonder if I can automate
this and somehow at the start of the
pandemic I had a bunch of free time all
the meetings that I would normally have
been at were canceled they hadn't moved
online yet they were just canceled
so I was able to whip up a very early
prototype version and thought well I
couldn't possibly use this yet I thought
sure it's worked in local testing what's
the worst that can go wrong really yeah
we might have to apologize and say okay
we'll we'll go back to doing it manually
let's just give it a go so I think that
it was only the third service was the
first time that Zuma enhance was used in
anger in production
um and the the point of zoom and enhance
is very much on the zoom side of things
this is
deliberately for entirely Zoom based
worship
um this was a
later version of the UI than we started
with and you'll be able to tell
throughout this talk that I am not a UI
designer
um so we have various tabs you know it
is quite usable if you know what you're
doing it's very usable
um different tabs for things and the
director side was most of what I spent
during the service and that showed uh
you know all the different scenes you
had the different videos to show and the
people that you wanted to spotlight
but it was just for this
purpose and initially the only user was
me I got a couple of other people within
our church to use it then there were
various uh sort of training calls where
different churches would get together
and say oh well we're doing things like
this we're streaming to YouTube We're
streaming Facebook we're streaming to
zoom whatever
um and different concerns So within TMC
we have always had a zoom service that
is the link to it is not shared outside
the church family
because then we don't need to worry
about Zoom bombing
um gdpr and copyright things get simpler
we don't stream it publicly
um we now I'll talk talk about now later
on
um but other churches have gone live on
Facebook all kinds of different things
so people got together and I mentioned
zoom and hunts and they said oh that
sounds really useful so I now have about
a dozen users it's a small but none uh
non-single digit number of users and
everything is around Zoom
okay
um that was almost a distraction and
that was developed um I pretty much
stopped developing it the by the end of
2020 it was all done
and eventually we were able to move to
more of a hybrid Church model TMC has
been relatively conservative in terms of
pandemic things
um
but that meant that where some Churches
opened up in person back in September
2020 we were still all the way through
uh all of 2020 and into 2021 we were
working at doing everything over Zoom
but we could see I knew that eventually
we would want to go hybrid and by hybrid
I mean some people in the church
building
and some people at home
and my use of words there is very
deliberate and
I I worked out a few things early in the
pandemic
um one was hey with zoom Services we are
able to provide a worship experience for
people who are housebound who might not
have been able to come to TMC the
building
um in the before times
when we can all get back in the building
most of us we should not let that group
of people down we must be providing Zoom
Services as long as we have the
resources to do so and I will make
desperately I will try desperately hard
to make sure we continue to provide to
have those resources
that was one the other is the church is
not the building
lots of people said oh when when we get
back to church no we're in church
already
um
we can be worshiping I I was uh on
holiday in Wales and still dialed into
the zoom service I was in church as far
as I was concerned so I always and I I
correct myself when I get it wrong I
refer to the church building when I mean
the building
um because again getting back to code
because you're here for Cody saying that
stuff names matter so if you mean the
church building say the church building
so hybrid church was always going to be
some people in the church building some
people at home
it's happened slightly slower than I'd
expected but I I kind of was modeling
three situations one is ten percent of
people
in the church building 90 at home and
that was
the middle of 2021
there was a 50 50 split which I thought
would be quite short
um where half of the worshipers for any
given service would be in the church
building and half at home and then the
9010 where most people are in the church
building but we still have some people
at home on zoom and we want to make them
feel that they are completely part of
the service which means deliberately
making sure that sometimes we have
people doing a reading or doing a prayer
on Zoom even if we've got people who
could do it in the church building but
you don't want that second class feeling
so that this was what I was planning
while we were still on Zoom
and so I started coming up with some
requirements for actual service so at
your service is the name of the the
second app
um named because it's the thing that
helps you deliver your service and it is
meant to serve you
um so hence that
if I refer to ays that's the
um obvious acronym for it
but whereas zoom and enhance was just me
using it and a few other very technical
people from other churches
I wanted At Your Service to be something
that would be as easy to use at least as
the previous system remember the the
scary mixer
previously people only had to worry
about projecting words onto a screen
and turning microphones on and off
we were going to be introducing more
stuff in there and occasionally people
would bring Powerpoints and it's like oh
well if you've got a PowerPoint we'll
put John or someone else from The Av
team who's comfortable with with tech
stuff like it should be easier than that
so I wanted to make it more powerful
than the previous system but at least a
simple ideally simpler
we know we knew that we needed to have
cameras and I'd already been speccing
out
um a camera a pan tilt zoom camera a PTZ
um that we would Mount at the back of
the church that could then
um you know Zoom pan over and zoom in to
show the pulpit or the lectern or
whatever
and this part about sound integration
was
the realization that if you ask people
to use two different systems the
computer system and the mixer where the
mixer was terribly scary but you only
needed bits of bits of it
that would not be great
on the other hand there's something
physically compelling about pressing a
button that makes that's really
intuitive in terms of UI for the muting
and unmuting I'll come back to that but
we've also got well you've got to be
able to join a zoom meeting and
Spotlight Zoom can you imagine if I'd
said okay well I won't integrate
anything and this is where Dan's point
about the Unix philosophy my
ays is the opposite of the Unix
philosophy in some ways it's one tool
that does everything for you
because I don't want people to have to
learn several tools so if they'd had to
say okay well if I'm going to do Zoom
spotlighting I will open up the Zoom app
and manually find the right person and
Spotlight them uh to to change the sound
I will go into the mixer and unmute that
bit if I want PowerPoint I will launch
PowerPoint Etc
no people want to do want an integrated
system I believed
I wanted to be able to record things
really useful for weddings and baptisms
just as a value add for the church you
know people
obviously people from the church get
married and have babies but also people
get married who we've never seen before
or who have some
um relative connection
and it's always nice to be able to say
and we can give you a nice video of your
big day
um and there's some video playback as
well
okay
the things that I have found oh about
audio mixing I was looking earlier on
I'm in no way saying that Dan was boring
to watch no way at all but I was uh
looking at this now I know new trick
speaker connection and seeing between
the the lights here uh these XLR plugs
that I'm pretty sure are taking DMX
connections I wouldn't have known
anything of this before you learn so
much
um mostly useless information
as soon as you get into the AV world
it's a really interesting domain
in terms of audio mixing we have quite a
few microphones
um we now because I am an incorrigible
eBay microphone purchaser now uh the
church has several microphones that it
now owns and my shed which is my garden
office where I keep all my tech stuff
and work
um now it has more microphones than
really any shared needs and more than I
can actually physically get into my
mixer which is a bit embarrassing
so we have quite a few microphones but
at any time we only need two or three on
and we don't need to do very much with
them so mixers are incredibly versatile
bits of bits of Kit these days but
really the day-to-day once we've set it
up the day-to-day is mutant unmute the
preacher or the you know the the scene
group or the band or whatever and change
some levels the complicated bit is you
sometimes need to change the level in
the church building separately from the
level in that's going out to zoom
um so for example you don't necessarily
want to order want to amplify the band
that they're already being where our
band is flutes and baritones and things
and um a drum kit they're already loud
enough in the building
but you do want to obviously pick them
up and amplify to zoom
so let me show you the the evolution we
started with
a full-blown analog mixer
and I didn't like that idea I can't
control this at all from software
foreign
so this is the actual mixer that we've
got this is the one of mine in my shed
um and this is a Behringer xr18
um
I would normally have brought along
for demo purposes a spare xr16
um that is the same apart from not being
an audio interface I.E there's no USB
port
um but my rucksack was already quite
heavy with other things and I've also
not brought as many cameras as I
normally would however compare you know
this is still horrible looking I don't
want anyone dealing with the AV to have
to look at that or deal with it but
that's okay because there are almost no
knobs and buttons on this there's a
power switch on the side
that we don't use because we just turn
it on
um with the rest of the power there's a
headphone volume knob up there that we
don't touch at all
everything else it's just connections
it's a bunch of XLR cables
um two rows of inputs one row of outputs
and a network port in fact there are two
Network ports the the one that's empty
there is for ultranet monitoring cunning
stuff the one that's sort of mostly
hidden in the top left is the control
part and that's what's interesting
because give me a network connection and
a documented protocol and I can control
things
so that's all very well uh but the only
way of muting things if you don't have
something to control it
um is by pulling out the leads and I
don't want to be doing that
so let's see what software the xr18
comes with
well this is one page of it this is the
the mixer page oh so uh yeah
um so you have all the channels down at
the bottom and then up at the top you
have either Channel input gate equalizer
um compressor the various ways it's
really really complicated I don't know
my way around this
um because it can do so many things it's
got various special effects things that
you can have either in line or uh uh I
can't even remember what the name for
having it adjacent is
it's all really complicated I use one
effect on our church one which is I
change a stereo stereo input into a mono
basically
just combine them in the simplest
possible way so again this is something
I did not want to give to users at all
because it's got nearly as many knobs
and buttons as the horrible Hardware
mixer
just kind of disguised
this is my software
uh using WPF
and bits of this are open source and
bits aren't uh the the underlying
library that allows you to do this is
open source I can't remember any of the
GUI isn't there are complicated reasons
why it's not all open source obviously
I'd like to make it all open
um
but this does just what my users need
it has mutant on mute it has levels and
it does also let you if you see at the
top you're probably a bit far away uh to
see details but
where I've got input faders which may
not be a great uh description of it it's
got main or Panther work laptop or
sleepy
I mentioned that you might want
different levels for different outputs
so what's in the church building versus
what's going out via Zoom well you can
say I want to just see faders for
um one output at a time or you can put
it onto all and it will show several
faders for each input
again that's a bit complicated it's not
something you want to do in the middle
of a service you don't want to have to
switch to the right tab
and then find the right checkbox
so firstly I don't want you to have to
do that at all if possible everything
should be pre pre-programmed as much as
possible
and secondly we want some Hardware
having taken some Hardware away I want
to reintroduce it and this is an X touch
Mini
I wanted to bring it in person to show
the size of it the Mackie X12 that I
mentioned before is sort of about that
size
this is much smaller it consists of
eight knobs that also are pressable
there are little lights that go around
it you can see on there sort of flower
lights and two rows of buttons which
light up
and for our particular purpose I have no
idea actually what these are generally
used for because
this sort of thing is called a control
surface there are various control
surfaces often annoyingly complicated or
less programmable than you would like
um
but this feels perfect for our uses so
you can mute or unmute by pressing the
button and if it lights up it's live
you can change the volume that's being
output by the main so in the church
building it's the building amplifier
I've now got it so that you can have a a
secondary output that if you press and
hold the knob you can change the volume
but uh that's going out via Zoom but
that's less often used
but this is really useful for the
it's the 20 case of okay well I've
switched over to the preacher and she
suddenly said okay can we get the
handheld mic out and um pass that around
the congregation for ideas and you say
yep that's fine I will just press the
button that's labeled handheld mic
um
these are just dymo labels on the top by
the way uh you'll see that now I've got
slightly more of them on here
um in the AV world there's something
called a scribble strip which is you you
just write stuff on a strip
and then presumably erase it somehow but
dymo is fine for this some have digital
scribble strips I have a bit of Hardware
called the icon platform that again I
got on eBay because it sort of felt like
it would be fun to try
um it's too big for what the church
needs but would be great in that it's
got proper faders instead of these knobs
are slightly non-ideal but they're not
bad
um and the fun thing about the icon
platform is they're motorized faders so
I'll show you a video later on of you
control the faders yes you can move them
by hand but you can also move them by
software
always fun
okay let's do some actual Tech stuff
looking back at this WPF app
the mixer exposes an interface via osc
this open Sound control system which is
somewhat documented
and I wanted to write a WPF app that was
reasonably wpfe you know all view models
how do you go about
doing this if if I move a slider here
what should it do
obviously it's got to send something to
the mixer to say please change the the
fader level
but when I get a signal back do I change
the same property that is also bound to
the control
I've got two different sources of Truth
I've got what the user has done
on the GUI and I've got what the mixer
has told me
and those two sources of Truth can be
irritating Excuse me while I redo my
laces
better than falling over
I found an interesting
Paradigm whatever whatever you want to
call it for doing gui's in this sort of
system
which is the user can try to move the
slider
as much as they want and when they do
I'll get a signal saying the user wants
to move it to whatever
if the mixer doesn't respond
um that slider will not move at all
because the only thing that the
displayed version comes from is the
mixer
so you have this weird thing of you set
a property and then if you read the same
property again very very very shortly
afterwards it won't show that value
it won't show its until it is actually
the truth
which is a little bit confusing
um
initially and you know coming back to
Dan's talk and is that idiomatic as a
way of doing GUI development I'm not a
GUI either designer or implementer
normally I have found in this situation
where
this is actually responds really really
quickly it's fine
I'll come onto the mobile app a little
bit later time is running away from me
as always
but that that notion of what's what's
the truth what what should a GUI display
is something that had bugged me before
when I was writing code for my drum kit
um
and it would be it's something that I
haven't seen in any GUI tutorials and
things
maybe because they're not integrating
with Hardware but the only source of
Truth until you hit save is the
in-memory representation well that's a
lovely world to be in
but it really doesn't match to uh what I
need for this particular project
okay
uh
uh okay one bit of interesting
interesting architecture that I was
forced into and turned out to be a good
thing
um I mentioned the zoom SDK now I have
my beefs with zoom SDK and oauth but
leaving those aside for a while the zoom
SDK would only work in 32 bits it now
does have a 64-bit version
and the protocol that I'm using to
connect with cameras cameras such as
this
there are two
um
protocols involved one is visca which is
I think Sonny came up with it a long
time ago and it used to go over rs232
collections
these days we use visca over
IP
and that's for controlling so that's
move the camera up a bit down a bit left
a bit right a bit zoom in zoom out
um change the color balance all kinds of
things that I don't actually use
and the other is ndi now there are lots
of ways of getting
um data from cameras but ndi happens to
be the one that I've picked to use
um because it provides low latency that
I really do kind of need
um and it seems to be pretty reliable
all the cameras that you can get do
support
um rtmp rtsp all these other things
but I've integrated ndi
and that's given me a fair amount of
control again ndi has an SDK
like the Zoom SDK I've had to sort of
wrap it a bit and modify it a bit
um I would love to be able to open
source some of the modifications I've
made to the c-sharp bits of the ndi SDK
but that's not open source
um the zoom SDK claims to be open source
but actually isn't they took down their
GitHub repo and said right you can
download a zip file and it says this is
community developed like there's no way
of providing any code back anyway
um
when I got a second camera for my shed
um I found that if I had two cameras
open
and delivering
frames uh so 1920 by 1080
um in 30 frames a second
uh then every so often I would just run
out of memory
um I'm sure there are ways that I could
tweak that
but the whole thing just crashed
I thought if this were a 64-bit process
I would be fine and I tried doing that
so initially remove the zoom bit
try ndi with multiple sources it's all
good
so I need to use the zoom SDK because I
want to join Zoom meetings send Zoom
chat messages do Zoom spotlighting Etc
but I also want to have the ndi side of
things and that was the first client as
a server that I ended up with so start a
new process of a 32-bit process that
just does ndi sorry just a zoom
and it opens a web port
8080 and lets you post messages from the
main GUI into the zoom server and when I
say Zoom server I don't mean what Zoom
would consider a server it's the local
bit that just does this communication
and it's a horribly ugly hack that I
initially just did because it would work
I thought it's gonna be ugly but it'll
work
and then one day when I wasn't actually
in the church building I was preaching
somewhere else At Your Service crashed
and the zoom meeting kept going
because the zoom server
was still running
my friend Lola reopened at your service
and it all just continued so I'd
introduced this sort of reliability
separation
entirely because of an artificial limit
but it turned out to be really handy so
the zoom SDK now supports 64 bits I
might use to 64 it might use the 64-bit
SDK in the future but I'm going to keep
that separation so the idea of
an application being in two parts one
being the GUI that does still does most
of the operations
and something else that it talks to
which can be annoying sometimes because
you're wanting to find out how many
participants have I got on Zoom every
um at the moment what are the latest
chat messages Etc
I'm using polling I'm polling I think
the zoom bit twice a second or something
to say well what participants are there
now what participants are there now it's
kind of annoying but it works and it
does provide this extra reliability
that whole idea became really really
useful later on
let me just
go over some of the bits where I've been
doing integrating and I really want to
get over how much fun it has been
doing this integration where there's
been appropriate documentation the most
amazing bit was the visca part so
the first camera I got was PTZ Optics
and there are a bunch of cameras like
this Minn array zowie Tech
um PTZ Optics and a few others and
they're largely the same with different
levels of support and support from
different countries
um
but the PTZ Optics user manual and I
think the others as well show all the
viscer commands say right these are the
bytes that you should send and these are
the bytes you'll get back this isn't
particularly aimed at developers as a
product I don't think so I was surprised
them really pleasantly surprised by this
but I had no idea how to send them it's
like
it's on Port 1054 10 054.
um
or sorry six seven eight nine is the PTC
Optics one by default
um send visca packets I was like but
what's in a risk packet you've told me
this bit of the data bit but what does
the what does the rest of this packet
look like oh there isn't any those are
the bytes you send and it will move it's
like okay well I can try that
try that the camera moved and that the
exhilaration and Delight of
um sending a sending literally about
four bytes and the camera goes
wow that's amazing
so these are the integration points
um midi I use for the X such mini
um and also entirely separately our
church organ supports midi and as it
happens our organist has been recording
himself playing hymns over the last few
years
before the pandemic struck so now
because he's getting older as we all are
um but he's rather older than the
average in in this room and is worried
that if he has a fall or something there
are relatively few organists in the
church what do we do well now you can
have a midi file play it back through
the church organ
but from at your service and it's as if
David is there it's wonderful
um and that that's literally a case of
just send the midi data down I don't
need to care what the midi data is
other than controlling the volume of it
uh whereas for this I had to find out
what midi commands because midi is
mostly for
someone's turned this note on you know
played this note at this volume with
this attack or whatever
which isn't quite the same as
um pressing buttons and turning knobs
so when you encapsulate that a bit and
and try to make that usable
you get one library that you can then
integrate into At Your Service
open Sound control is for the xr18 that
I mentioned before ndi for the actual
data from the cameras
viscer I've mentioned for pen tilt Zoom
Joe I'm not actually going to go through
all this you can read it for yourself
but it's there's a lot of stuff
I will mention the foot pedal yeah
this is the easiest semi integration
I've actually abandoned this because it
turns out I can't multitask
um I used to play in the junior Church
band
um the the junior Church bit of it is a
misnomer
but the the idea was I would be able to
play the recorder and change the words
that were being shown on on screen
but if I've got to reach for
a hardware button or or even a key well
all my fingers are kind of busy
but you can get USB foot pedals that you
can then program so all I had to do was
program it to be right arrow plug it in
and then I'm playing along
press your foot down words change keep
playing yeah it turns out I then forgot
to change the words because I'm too busy
playing or I'll get the wrong notes so
that sort of integration that does that
did work but
um didn't work in my brain
and finally Google Cloud Storage
um for installers useful and more
importantly service resources
okay I've sort of talked about it quite
a lot let me show you what I mean and we
can actually use this demo bit to
evaluate not the code but the result
against Dan's Cupid properties
so
this is
At Your Service the main
UI now
one of the weird things about this was
designing it so that you could use it at
home
and you could use it in the church
building
because you want to be able to prepare
stuff at home and test it
well I've got two monitors at home but
actually I don't have two monitors when
I'm doing stuff on the sofa
um so I'm going to move the window a bit
because if you don't have a second
monitor connected it sort of thinks well
I'll use the top right hand side of the
screw the screen
to be your fake
um projector
so if I show a video I can just double
click and let me pause this briefly
um
the idea of a scene within a service
is that has everything you need for one
chunk of the service so that could be
some prayers or a hymn or whatever it is
and that needs to turn the mics on and
off start a video start showing words
Etc and this was where I was absolutely
Keen to have yes we've got a hardware
mixer
sorry a bit of Hardware control
but you shouldn't have to use it very
often because most of the time all you
need to do is move to the right scene
and everything will be ready for you
just make it all integrated
um I will now show the video just
because it's quite fun of this is the
icon platform that I mentioned before
and it's it's just a bit weird
to see these
um
motorized faders doing their own thing
that's about that wide and about that
deep and only has eight so we we could
have 16 but it does have a digital
scribble strip at the very top you might
see it saying mCP mode selected I've now
got it so that it would display the um
the titles of each of the channels
automatically but I've never used this
in the church building
so let's first look at composability
for this application you've seen most of
you've seen ninety percent of what what
you should do with uh At Your Service
now is once you've got a service ready
you go from scene to scene and then if
you've got ones with some words
you go from one page of words to another
and then you might need to move cameras
around
this is a fake camera so the green bit
is where it's sort of zoomed into so if
we if we decide to zoom in
the rectangle gets smaller or bigger
but let's do that do that with a more
interesting
um camera
so let's oh
let's zoom in on down as I know he won't
mind
um so this is this is a sort of fake pen
tilt zoom camera obviously it's not got
any moving heads everything is more fun
when it actually physically moves around
I would say oh where there are lights
that come on
um so far I have resisted I've got
myself uh a little set of LEDs a bit
like these these lights and a laser and
some things that I control with DMX
I have so far resisted getting a DMX
Sparks machine so you know when when on
Strictly or whatever as they come out
load of Sparks come up you can control
those from your computer ah doesn't that
sound fun I haven't got one I have
absolutely no excuse for getting one so
I'm not doing so
however
um you can see that we've got multiple
pages of text and we can do a few text
effects
let me stop the scene and let's go in
and look at the composition of that
because it is all completely composed
each scene consists of a bunch of
different things and no one aspect of it
other than text I'll mention knows about
what else is going on
so you can have PowerPoint and a camera
in the same scene
and even media and
start showing a video and then bring
PowerPoint to the front and then do
other things
and some of these would not make sense
together
because they're not really orthogonal
showing a video and showing a PowerPoint
you would normally just put the video
into PowerPoint but there's no point in
prohibiting it so let's just keep it
there
um text is slightly interesting in that
I've got two modes for text
which depends on whether anything else
is coming up on the screen obviously
sound is orthogonal to whatever's being
displayed
but this is another example of this does
exactly what I need it to for my
particular use case and this is the joy
of doing a a project for
a small user base where you know the
requirements absolutely so if I show
text with camera
that will show
the words in the bottom
and that's how we display hymn words
on a Sunday morning with a con a camera
pointing at the congregation
and we can then people at home can see
other people singing along they're
they're happy they see their friends
it's all good and we bring the words up
at the bottom
at other times it may be that you don't
actually want any cameras
in which case
you don't want all that wasted space
so you can have text on its own
but at that point
you can get more onto the screen so this
is the same
text file thong whatever you want to
call it
and if you're not displaying anything
else we've got the idea of half pages
and if you've got camera or anything
else showing we display half a page at a
time
if you haven't we display a full page at
a time it's very very very specific I
wouldn't expect any other software
package to have this functionality and
the idea is you really can
um
show the same source so this is all
if I go and edit again it's in a file
and
I can't zoom in easily but it's it's a
sort of markdown like thing where I've
got triple equals is a full page break
and triple
hyphens is a half page break and if you
put the hyphens in Brackets then it's um
then it makes the half page break not
have a line break if I
I've got live preview so this is with
a half page break that would normally be
between two short verses of a hymn again
it's really specific to our use case but
if you've got long verses you don't want
that extra blank line
so you can display the same the same
text in two different ways
so coming back to Dan's Cupid the
application is composable in terms of
each scene is very much composed from
Individual bits
um it's also composable in terms of once
a scene is going
you can still change with either the
hardware
um
or
ah
the mixer tab so I'm not connected to a
real mixer at the moment
um
but if I move the
coming back to what I was saying earlier
on if I move the slider that has to talk
to a fake mixer to know that it can
actually move
so I've got a mixer that responds to the
same kind of Open Source can uh control
protocol but just don't connect to
anything physical otherwise that button
wouldn't move at all the the slider
won't move so people can do that at the
time likewise you can move the cameras
around
whether you've put a camera into the
scene or not you can always override it
in the
um at the time
it's definitely not Unix philosophy in
that it is meant to be one tool that
does everything
but within that tool they're sort of
compartmentalized bits of functionality
what's P down I've forgotten
predictable
mostly
oh this one bug so for the most part
everything works fine
um
yes but only once I've worked out what
it was Dan asked whether the bug was
consistent I had a bug
um around sound
so if I if I start a new service
and it does nice things like uh this has
suggested that if I use the test service
template it's going to come up with a
title of 2022 05 15 test 15 May
that's because the 15th of May is the
next Sunday you can say in your
templates file which has no GUI to edit
it whatsoever because I'm going to be
the only person ever doing this it's
just a Json file you can say this kind
of service always happens on a Sunday
um and at a particular time of day and
it will say well when's the next one of
those going to be that's probably what
you mean
so most of the time you can say new
service and just okay
and then we've got templates within that
and
okay so when I clicked on song
sorry the text is really small because
it doesn't have a presentation mode as
it were
um it's put the short sm58 microphone as
on by default
it turned out and if I yeah let me
demonstrate the next bit which is
some funky song
so we've got three bits in this service
and then I'm preparing this at home I
can then synchronize with the cloud
um
it's gonna fail because it's on my
custom Network here rather than being
able to get to Google Cloud Storage
where everything is actually stored but
it would say oh I will synchronize up
any changes to songs you've made and any
um any new Services Etc
foreign I had a weird bug where if you
had synchronized
and then you did a new service then a
load of the templates lost what their
mixer controls were
for weird reasons that unfortunately it
was hard to make the the code AS
idiomatic as I would have liked to
because basically
some of these are effectively Singletons
they're not Singletons within the code
but you know everything
um the window has a reference to this is
what I think the world is this is what I
think the templates are Etc
well if you synchronize down some new
templates
you need to remember to reload your
in-memory representation that the window
has of those templates otherwise things
get out of sync
so it was really easy to fix once I
found it but I I only saw it because I
noticed various services that didn't
have all the sound attached to them that
they should so you know you bring up a
hymn and
there would be you know all the mics
would be muted right this is bad I will
try to reproduce this new song no it's
fine it's only
if you do synchronization and it changes
a configuration so it needs to reload
stuff and then you do new new service
like that was not fun to to work out
uh uh idiomatic
it tries to be as idiomatic as I can
make it
um from the perspective of people who
are going to use this so
I would love a better name than Cloud so
cloud and synchronize
and this comes a little bit into the D
bit of domain driven
um cloud and synchronized probably
aren't terms that half of my users will
really want it's easy enough for them to
learn that's one thing to do
but most stuff is in terms of songs for
example you browse the song database
there's nothing inherently songy
about most of this they're just
effectively text files all smooshed into
one big file
um but well they do have copyright and
ccli and you know a few other bits of
metadata that are song like
but it's much easier for people to
understand that than
um
if I just said you know text aspects or
whatever and I have a fairly friendly
about bit with you can show the log
check for updates in fact I think show
the log is only only displayed if you're
in an advanced mode so
I have an advanced menu item here with
encrypt some text
um that's used for various reasons and
switching configurations because I want
to be able to do my demo configuration
and my church configuration and my
development configuration
um no one else wants to see that menu so
they don't
ended up seeing it so I would say it's
idiomatic
to a to a degree on that front and the
domain driven
I will demonstrate in terms of code
rather than application
so Dan you will be hopefully happy with
this I have folders here called camera
and Cloud Storage and initialization is
a bit vague but media midi playback
mixer monitors OBS PowerPoint Etc
and the same is replicated in the mobile
app
despite initially you start new mobile
app and it says here are your views here
are your view models and I said I don't
want to do that
uh I've unloaded it
and it's
it's a bit weird because in my mobile
app so in in the main application each
of those folders has quite a few bits of
code because it does quite a lot the
mobile app
um does almost nothing which means each
of these folders has two or three files
now I've done two different versions of
the mobile app which is really overkill
for a mobile app but only one person has
ever used
um the second one I tried was avalonia
UI
and I thought okay I'll stick with views
and view models and to some extent it
did feel better because I just got two
folders one had just views in one had
just few models in
but I've ended up keeping this as the
Maui app I've kept it this way and I
think I will keep it this way because I
can name everything the same way in the
mobile app that it's named in the main
application and it's all consistent
okay let's knit back I've got six
minutes that's not nearly a time enough
never mind
I've shown you the um
X touch Mini
but that's only one of the extra bits of
hardware
the other is a stream deck
out of Interest how many folks have seen
stream decks before
oh not many
these are lovely bits of Kit um like
everything AV wise they're not terribly
cheap I think one of this will be about
130 pounds and the bigger one
um it's not that size but it's about
that size
um is about 200 pounds
and it's just a load of buttons
but it so happens that each button is
also a screen
and this is lovely because I have users
who don't really like using keyboard and
mouse and don't really want to be using
a computer at all
but if they've got a button that says
Helen and a button that says him one or
or you know
um low he comes with clouds descending
written
in fairly small text it would probably
only Show Low he comes but that's fine
they can press that button and they'll
know what it will do and it gets on with
stuff
and if they're trying to go to the right
page in a hymn
they can either see all the hymn words
down here
or realistically you don't need to go
hopping from page to page into him you
just want to go through the whole thing
linearly so I have this lovely next
button that is green until it goes red
when you reach the end and literally you
just need to keep oh end of the verse
I'll press next end of the verse I'll
press next end of the verse I'll press
next I've got some users
bear in mind that my total user base is
six or seven some people ignore this
completely and just use keyboard mouse
and the the PC user interface some
people use this almost exclusively and
don't touch anything else
so it's been really useful to find out
what different people like
and adjust things to them
it's sort of a tiny
the the requirements
um Loop feedback loop is really really
short which is great
um
so the way that I've typically worked
with all of this is I've had an idea for
something I will then generally make it
work and usually and I've got better at
this over time
but usually the first iteration of it is
a bit clunky in one way or another
but I've gone ahead right to make sure
it's ready to use in production so this
is in production every Sunday and
usually that means updating it from
the version that was previously
installed the previous Sunday because
there are changes every week
make it work use it and I take
a notebook
I've got a small notebook that I take to
the church building every time I'm on
duty and
I literally write little bullet points
um so yesterday I wrote uh you know
socket closed for Zoom Spotlight set
selection mode to none for mixers set
the tab to the first camera I haven't
implemented that yet you know if if a
scene has one camera on should I change
the tab in the advanced area to
highlight that one I don't know I'll
I'll think about doing that
I guess it's work teach other people to
use it and then find out what the Real
Pain points are because the ones that
you write
aren't going to be the ones that other
people find you know I can make it I can
go from hard to use to easy for me to
use but that's not the same as easy for
other people to use you need to find out
their their mental models
one of the Striking things has been uh
one of my users who I happen to know
best is younger than me very icy
literate
he in the first time that he was using
the app in production
having barely practiced with it before
he was thinking oh in that third hymn I
wonder whether I could show the band at
the top half of the screen and the
congregation at the second in the bottom
half of the screen and he was about to
do exactly the right thing to do that
and I would say
it would work but let's just take things
a bit easier
but he got the right man or rather he
got the same mental model as me very
very quickly
so what else have we been doing since
this started I started writing this on
February the 6th 2021
so it's been 15 months and we started
with one camera at the back of the
church and I thought that's going to be
fine cameras are expensive they're about
the the ones we use are about 1700
pounds each new
and I thought so one is going to be
plenty for everyone 640k will be enough
for everyone
and then we found reasons to have two
more cameras and one both of those
reasons actually sound quite trivial but
have made an enormous difference
we've now got two cameras one in the
center and one a bit off to the side
and the problem is people feeling a bit
seasick because
our lectern
you would see over here and then we've
got a Pulpit which is only used for
doing readings these days
um over here
if you swing a camera over in terms of
panning
you get this feeling and it makes you
feel seasick at least made me feel
seasick I ended up saying okay well if I
know that it's panning over from one to
another I can fade it down move it over
fade it back up that's great but then
you've got
bit of black for a while and it's
it interrupts the worship
it's really really important to me that
all of this is just enabling something
else
it's great and fantastic for a tech
perspective and that's great for me
but 99 of my church is not me
they don't want Tech they want to
worship smoothly and it fade into black
and then saying oh there's something
wrong with zoom
is not a good experience if we've got
two cameras one can be pointed at the
pulpit one of the lectern or lexan
pulpit and switch from one to the other
and it just is seamless
we've got another camera that's at the
front pointing at the congregation for
three reasons
um
the one that I immediately as soon as we
started using this for weddings thought
I really want a camera at the front is
the entrance to the bride
I'm going to give people a video of
their wedding you really want to see the
bride being able to come in and you know
it's a it's a big moment for everyone
we could only do it from when she was
about halfway up and that we'd then get
the back of her head and we can sort of
follow her up and tilt but it's not the
same as being able to see it see her
face on
the second was dear to my heart because
my wife Holly runs the guides and
brownies units
um in in our church and when they're
doing a parade you want to be able to
see the guides and brownies parading in
and the third which I hadn't really
anticipated was
um when people at home are watching and
singing along with a hymn they like to
be able to see the faces of the
congregation who are also singing them
rather than the backs of their heads
so we now have three cameras
um which is wonderful unfortunately it's
sort of unfortunately that means I've
got to have three Zoom cameras at home
as well mine are cheaper not knock off
ones but they're bought from eBay rather
than new etc etc but my shed is
massively over provisioned for a shed
um
things like
an improvement over our previous system
where the only place that we had Zion
Works installed was on the church
computer in the church building so you
had to either go up
the day before or be Brazen enough to
say I will rock up at quarter past 10
and hope that I can put the service
together in quarter of an hour before
starting well no it's really useful to
be able to prepare it at home
synchronize it up to the cloud then in
the church building synchronize it down
and you're away
the mobile app I'm yeah I'm out of time
so I will finish with the mobile app
this was actually almost a dare from a
friend of mine it's like well you
finished now right you you've got
nothing else to do
um next you'll do a mobile app as I know
that would be very very silly oh but um
would it at least be feasible this is
the nice thing about a hobby if someone
said that at work saying oh right now
you've done this you can do this silly
thing you just say no I've got more
important things to do
but it sounds fun
and Maui's coming out I've been keeping
an eye on Maui this would be a great
opportunity to try it
I started the mobile app on Tuesday
um and on Sunday I was using it in
production
just being able to say that and I'm not
a mobile developer just want to really
emphasize that
I used the same idea that I'd had before
of having
a desktop app that was also a server so
this time the main
um
the main UI
which I've now stopped
um
it starts in fact now two ports one a
UDP Port so the mobile app can just
discover the system automatically if
it's on the same subnet yay
um so you start the app and it says I've
connected to actual service
um the appropriate configuration Etc
but it also starts on HTTP Port that the
mobile app just pulls saying what scenes
have you got what what are the text of
the currently selected scene
um what PowerPoint I didn't show the
PowerPoint presentation is very cool
because you can ask the PowerPoint SDK
or interop level to render the
PowerPoint slides to images so I can
then send those images to both the
stream deck so as well as text saying
what the hymns are it can show you
little little thumbnails of PowerPoint
slides and you can also get them on the
mobile app say oh yes that's the slide I
want now instead of just slide one slide
two Etc these little things that make my
day
um and it's all just Jason over just
HTTP it's not even https because you
know what shared certificate am I going
to have Etc might do something about
that but actually the security no one
else is on that Network in the church
building because we've got a you know
separately provisioned ones for guest
access Etc
and it's been genuinely useful I'm now
out of very much House of time anyway
the main thing I want to get across
is this bottom thing writing software
that you see being used is rewarding
it's rewarding for you for Tech things
you know I could go on I've said about
half of what I've learned doing all of
this it's immensely fun
interoperating with Hardware is
immensely fun as well because you get to
integrate with all the great things that
other people have done
um but
just you can use it for learning trying
things out and deliver value to other
people and people that you know and they
can come up to afterwards and say that
was really useful how about if we could
do something slightly different
um so I hope you will go away and do
something amazing that's got nothing to
do with AV but maybe has integration
with other Hardware because it's fun but
does something useful and you can learn
at the same time I'm massively over time
but thank you very much